I was checking out our reddit discussion
forum this morning at david pakman.com
slash read it lots of really interesting
conversations debates and discussions
happening there not the least of which
is a discussion about how likely I
believe the u.s. is to enter into a
nuclear conflict under Donald Trump's
watch and a lot of discussion about that
happening really just a lot of concern
about North Korea among the nearly 4100
viewers and listeners that are now
subscribed to the reddit discussion
forum and understandably so this is
clearly a major issue right now around
the world I think the odds are very low
maybe they're only 5 percent but the
severity of that actually happening is
what's drawing so much attention to it
and while important well in the next
thread that I'll put up on the screen
for you there is another one of our
participants on reddit who says there is
a zero percent chance that North Korea
will attack the United States first sort
of arguing that despite the bluster from
North Korea about Guam or we might build
this or send that that they are not so
erratic there that they would actually
make a first strike against the United
States and thus it's really a matter of
his Donald Trump going to take
pre-emptive action and I think that
they're I don't think it's a zero
percent chance that North Korea attacks
the United States first but I do believe
that it is a very low percentage chance
unless Donald Trump's rhetoric is just
so out there that it impacts Kim jong-un
in a way that we've not seen before and
actually causes him to take some kind of
first action against the u.s. I could
see them flexing their military might in
the waters around Guam imagining them
attacking Guam preemptively I just don't
see it I don't see it either also from
our reddit discussion forum how to fix
poverty why not just give people money a
link to an interesting NPR article that
discusses among other things the impact
of a universal basic income something
I've talked about quite a bit I would
say basic income is one of the more
discussed issues on the reddit
discussion forum don't you think I would
think so we talk a lot about it on the
bonus show too it's a very tough thing
to market though it's definitely trying
to win conservatives over on the idea
when you talk about giving people money
I'll say especially people who don't
deserve it which is the main thing that
the right seems to be
turned with also from our reddit
discussion forum this is really funny
you should check this out if the US had
state TV in North Korea it would look
like this
and basically what has been done is
there's linked to YouTube videos where
you have the narration from Fox News and
other right-wing media superimposed onto
North Korean state media where they make
announcements like for example that Kim
jong-un was born on the you know there
was a double rainbow today he was born
or he got 18 holes in one during a round
of golf or whatever and it is a very
very clever thing and I encourage you to
check it out did you see these little
videos no I haven't but you know CNN
anchor John King tongue-in-cheek said
that Fox News with state-run media now
in a sense it's not unsympathetic to
that idea they're journalists don't push
back and have you seen Hannity Hannity
now is fully just been Trump
propagandist at this point also from our
reddit discussion forum a link to my
video from a couple years ago where I
made Spanish tortilla in a YouTube video
and demands for not only a pat live
stream but also more cooking videos and
maybe someday I will cook again I was
thinking about a video tutorial for how
to make curried coffee well that would
be a very short video be funny though I
mentioned earlier last week that I will
be teaching at Boston College starting
in the fall I was recently given a tour
of like the communication department
sort of headquarters and they've got
massive Keurig presence not brought
massive Keurig presence and I will not
be partaking I will put that on record
right now